good news everybody i know a lot of you
are worried about these skyrocketing
inflation keeping you from putting food
on the table and gas in your tank but
you have no reason to worry because
according to president biden
there is no more inflation
before i begin today i want to say a
word about
the news that came out today relative to
the economy
actually i just want to say a number
zero
today we received news that our economy
had zero percent inflation
in the month of july
zero percent
here's what that means while the price
of some things go up
went up last month the price of other
things went down
by the same amount
the result
zero inflation last month but people are
still hurting
but zero inflation last month
zero inflation zero
which
sounds great it just doesn't sound true
and joe biden has said plenty of things
that aren't true so then i i looked into
it a little bit turns out that wasn't
just the sort of gaffe that we've come
to expect from joe biden
that is the official line of the white
house zero inflation echoed by
vice president harris
this work
will mean more jobs more job security
and better pay
so
the president and my vision for the
future also means lowering costs
for americans today we learned
that last month our economy had zero
percent inflation
in july
we saw a drop in gas prices and a range
of other goods like clothing and
airfares and household appliances which
means
more money in the pockets of working
families
zero percent inflation and the only
problem with that claim is that we all
know it isn't true
we all know it isn't true because
everything we're buying or not buying in
sub cases because it's too expensive
is much costlier than it was a year ago
it's 8.5 percent more expensive on
average to be exact and we know that
because that is the year-over-year
inflation figure according to the
consumer price index
that number is slightly less than the
40-year high of 9.1 percent that we hit
the previous month but 8.5 is still
massive inflation it would be historic
inflation if not for the even more
insane number that happened the month
before to put all of this in perspective
the inflation rate when joe biden took
office was 1.4 percent now he is
celebrating 8.5
biden's claim that inflation is zero
doesn't even hold up from the
perspective of a month over month
calculation the month over month
inflation calculation would actually be
negative 0.6
and month-over-month inflation is a
ridiculous figure to use if everything
i'm buying right now is 8.5 percent more
expensive than it was a year ago that is
not a cause for celebration that's not a
cause for celebration that well at least
it's not 9.1 percent more expensive it's
the classic democrat playbook
screw things up beyond recognition
then when things in any way even
slightly improve claim victory and then
when people question your ridiculous
claim redefine all the words
so men are now women
babies are clumps of cells
and 8.5 percent is really zero who are
you going to believe joe biden or your
own lying bank account right now go to
ziprecruiter.com
knowles the last thing that i want to be
doing over the summer is sorting through
a ton of unqualified candidates resumes
whenever i feel like replacing one of
these producers over here i don't have
to sit with a stack of just random
resumes that is why
i use zip recruiter ziprecruiter does
the work for you and now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com knowles
ziprecruiter uses its powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job you can
easily review these recommended
candidates you can invite your top
choices to apply additionally
ziprecruiter has a complete suite of
tools that makes it easy to filter
review and rate your candidates four out
of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day no wonder ziprecruiter is
the number one rated hiring site based
on g2 satisfaction ratings as of january
1st 2022. so soak up all that summer has
to offer let zip recruiter do the work
for you are you ready for the url get a
pen out ziprecruiter.com knowles that is
where you can try it for free that is
ziprecruiter.com k-n-o-w-l-e-s
i'm so glad you liked that clip you know
thanks to you we hit 1 million
subscribers we're now over a million
subscribers here on youtube i would like
to hit 1 trillion
by hitting 1 trillion that will put me
well on my way to my real goal of
hitting
one quadrillion so please ring the bell
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]